here's a magic trick that Steve Barton
taught me with typical generosity
shortly after we met in 1962 yeah that
was a long time ago it just uses two
hands oh and under the pretext of
fairness I will roll up my sleeves and
it uses imaginary glitter just a little
bit there's quite a lot of that in this
room and a little squeeze looks almost
real looks like money
pure silver dollar of course if you
squeeze it again it can't stand that
kind of treatment it just sort of goes
away I don't know some people think it
goes up my sleeve it doesn't go up my
sleeve it goes right up will it goes
right up here some people think it goes
over here it doesn't go here at all you
see it just no no no it doesn't go here
no it goes right here there it is they
see it comes a break back heads or tails
tails or heads doesn't matter you know
there's only one way to make it come
back there's only one way to make it
come back and it'll stay back and that's
what Steve art and showed me I'll do it
just as slowly as I can
close one finger at a time that freckle
is actually a secret push button and if
I just pop the push button like that
well the coin is back and it's back to
stay
and that's what Steve Martin taught me
no kidding I met Steve Martin at Merlins
magic shop in Disneyland Steve had a
summer job behind the counter
pitching in expensive magic tricks to
the hundreds maybe thousands of
customers who flooded through the doors
every day even at 16 or 17 years old he
was pretty impressive he was a very good
magician he could make a sin galley deck
a very mundane trick deck of cards look
like a miracle he he was a master at
demonstrating and selling and he was
very very funny on his feet eight hours
a day he kept the customers laughing and
buying I was a very serious student of
sleight of hand not that man of course
was I wasn't nearly as funny as Steve
but man I wanted to be I struck up a
conversation and we became friends
almost instantly and eventually I joined
in behind the counter at Merlins magic
shop a great day for me and every day
when the store was about to close Steve
would call out last chance to make me
rich when he was in college Steve moved
on to Knott's Berry Farm performing in
the it's true performing in the bird
cage theatre and his summer job as a
Nana's weekend job to an actor in the
old-fashioned melodrama that the bird
cage theatre put on and as a comedy
magician in the solo acts Martin the
magic marvel he closed his act with a
very funny and pretty mysterious
floating ball illusion that he called
the toilet float trick at the end the
ball flew out through the audience
toward the exit door and as Steve chased
it down the aisle he called out it's
headed for the John
Steve has always made me laugh sometimes
literally to the point where I'd fall
out of my chair and suddenly one day as
if out of the blue he could play the
banjo it astounded me he was self-taught
he loved bluegrass and because he
realized that he needed another way to
entertain audiences with whom he didn't
necessarily have a language in common
well Steve has come back to the banjo as
you'll hear but it isn't because his
movie career didn't work out